[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prends mes arêtes je mets et je
couvre et comme pour le fumé de poisson
les regards sont attentifs pour beaucoup
c'est une nouvelle page professionnelle
qui s'écrit
[Musique]
à 39 ans Yann Bouty a décidé de revenir
sur les bancs de l'école ou plutôt dans
les cuisines de cette école de
gastronomie après plusieurs années dans
la pub
j'ai ma femme qui sait que je passionner
de cuisine et qui elle fait un métier
qui la passionne et qui m'a dit un jour
tu devrais essayer tu verras la vie est
plus sympa
et donc elle m'a poussé depuis 4-5 ans a
essayé de créer un projet et de d'aller
là-dedans et là je me suis senti prêt du
coup alors il a économisé pour vivre
cette passion qu'il anime depuis
l'enfance
petit à petit pour pas avoir un truc
trop liquide souvent les gens disent moi
ma mère cuisiner super bien et du coup
ça m'a donné envie de faire pareil
qu'elle et moi c'était vraiment
l'inverse c'est que mes deux parents
cuisaient très très mal
mais j'adorais manger et donc j'ai dû
apprendre tout seul à faire la cuisine
aujourd'hui ce Parisien voudrait ouvrir
son propre restaurant comme lui presque
tous les élèves de la classe sont des
reconvertis depuis quatre mois ils
apprennent les gestes les termes précis
sous l'œil attentif du formateur
premier jour qu'on a fait tous ici on a
fini la journée en se disant c'était
génial et quand on s'est demandé ce
qu'on avait fait on avait épluché quatre
carottes on les avait coupé mais juste
on les avait épluchés de la bonne
manière rangée au bon endroit nettoyer
comme il faut tailler dans le bon sens
et malgré ça on était tous hyper heureux
donc on s'est dit que c'était pas trompé
que les jeunes Bachelor qui ont à peine
18 ans tout ça ils savent ce qu'ils vont
ils ont tous un projet donc derrière il
faut il y en a il y en a qui ont
financés eux-mêmes il y en a par rapport
à l'état donc on a l'obligation de
résultat alors ça c'est ce qu'il faut
jamais faire ok
10 ans d'expérience qu'ils doivent
acquérir
là le but de l'exercice c'est de réussir
à dresser de manière
coordonnée comment resto pour que tout
sorte en même temps et chaud c'est un
super exercice pour le coup
on est prêt chef
[Musique]
du vinaigre
forcément les critiques du formateur ne
sont pas toujours tendres franchement
c'est fait
non non
après il y a toujours plein
d'interprétations la recette on peut la
donner au 13 je pense qu'on fera tous un
plat différent mais si c'est ça fait
deux heures qu'on est dessus donc
forcément on préfère en avoir d'autres
mais au moins on le fera plus
alors là tu as dit l'autre en fait
[Musique]
à 50 ans
elle aussi complètement changé de voix
cette ancienne communicante s'est créé
une petite bulle de bien-être
dans ce cabinet parisien elle fait de la
réflexologie plantaire je me suis pas
levé un matin en disant j'adore les
pieds je vais devenir réflexologue il y
a pas de côté fétichiste du tout parce
qu'il y a des gens qui me disent mais
c'est parce que t'es fait déçu non je
suis pas fétichiste des pieds
j'étais au même poste dans l'entreprise
que j'ai occupé pendant 25 ans depuis 7
ans et c'est vrai que
je commençais un peu à tourner en rond
il y avait pas vraiment d'évolution
possible et en fait j'ai commencé cette
formation parce que je me suis baladé
sur un salon bien-être sa lonzaine en
l'occurrence et j'avais trouvé des prix
type prospectus et donc au début ça a
été un peu comme une bulle d'air en fait
un petit peu
au départ comme un passe-temps pour
décompresser à nous suit une formation
quelques jours par mois pendant un an
elle décide d'en faire son métier juste
après la crise covid alors le
confinement va ça a été comme un sac à
côté comme un stop je pense que je suis
pas toute seule j'avais plus envie de
d'être sous pression de de
prendre les transports je faisais quand
même une heure ou 20 le matin 1h20 le
soir quand ça allait bien je me suis
finalement l'un dans l'autre je me suis
bah c'est le bon moment
ça m'a aidé peut-être à prendre
conscience des choses
un changement de vie radical qui
l'épanouit complètement
le bien-être il se voit tout de suite
parce que souvent je me dis je devrais
prendre les gens la figure des gens en
photo quand ils arrivent et quand ils
repartent ils ont plus la même tête
quand ils arrivent souvent ils sont
l'oeil terre ils sont fatigués ils sont
stressés et quand ils repartent le
visage est ouvert ils ont une lumière
dans les yeux franchement souvent c'est
c'est impressionnant quoi et ça c'est
juste c'est juste pour moi c'est
c'est un vrai une vraie un vrai plaisir
en fait
si les métiers du bien-être sont très
prisés des cadres en reconversion
d'autres le sont un peu moins
[Musique]
d'Héricault a choisi d'aller à
contre-courant
ingénieur en société de conseils il est
devenu il y a un an et demi prof de
maths
dans cet exemple là
oui vas-y j'ai h sur HF
C
tu vas voir là on est sur un sujet en
plus qui est assez symbolique le terme
de Thalès donc c'est important qu'ils
s'entraîne et qu'il soit hyper à l'aise
dessus et c'est très valorisant en fait
d'être enfin avec eux tous les jours de
le voir leur progrès de les aider c'est
ça qui me plaît beaucoup je sais
pourquoi je me lève le matin c'est il y
a pas de doute là-dessus contrairement à
avant ou parfois je me demandais un peu
donc là BC c'est bien l'hypoténuse donc
par semaine il enseigne les maths dans
ce collège de Seine-Saint-Denis
de 4 un environnement de travail bien
éloigné de son ancienne emploi
en classe il faut notamment apprendre à
imposer une certaine discipline au
travail
c'est la dernière fois que je vous le
dire
au début c'était un peu une appréhension
parce que
c'est jamais facile de s'imaginer être
de fond ton élève qui sont plein
d'énergie mais après il y a plein de
techniques qu'on peut avoir accès pour
petit à petit prendre l'assurance et
savoir comment gérer une classe
vous travaillez je dis c'est un cours
normal
alors si vous avez terminé
alors pour l'aider un professeur
expérimenté vient régulièrement le voir
en classe
avec j'ai du mal non tu as fait le plus
dur là il débrief ensuite tous les deux
vraiment tu dois imposer le silence il
faut que ce que tu dis est important
quoi en fait l'explication que tu leur a
donné à ce moment-là c'est la correction
c'est-à-dire que tu as corrigé et en
fait ta correction faisait explication
après un tout petit point toujours
là-dessus mais très rapidement c'est la
d'un point de vue purement mathématique
donc c'était à peu près 33% bon et tu
leur as dit bon c'est une valeur
approchée mais bon on va pas trop
s'embêter avec ça si il faut quand même
s'embêter avec ça quoi ça m'inspire
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de travail que
on apprend à chaque fois et que
on se rend pas compte quand on est dans
l'action de plein de choses et vraiment
ce regard et hyper hyper utile et hyper
enrichissant moi je suis assez
impressionné en vrai parce que il a que
un an et demi
d'ancienneté là et je trouve que il
s'autorise déjà à faire beaucoup de
choses d'un point de vue pédagogique le
résultat peut-être de son passé
professionnel comme lui l'enseignement
attire de plus en plus de profils de
reconvertie alors que les étudiants s'y
intéressent beaucoup moins je pense que
là le fait de d'avoir eu un autre métier
avant la mène à se poser différentes
questions et il lui donne cet envie là
alors qu'effectivement aujourd'hui de
moins en moins de monde à avoir envie
d'être prof oui ça c'est certain
[Musique]
en parallèle de ces cours au collège
Timothée prépare le CAPES
cette carrière il ne l'avait pourtant
jamais imaginé il y a quelques années
c'est l'association le choix de l'école
qui la convaincu l'organisme accompagne
les jeunes reconvertis à l'atelier
espère devenir titulaire à la fin de
l'année à 28 ans sa reconversion est
arrivée au bon moment malgré une perte
de salaire de 30% si vous avez besoin on
pourra organiser des ateliers un peu
collectifs groupés j'en parlais avec une
référence tout à l'heure justement
à 30 ans ou 35 ans avec quelques enfants
faire ce choix là c'est sûr et
aujourd'hui je suis très content de
d'être du côté où je suis plutôt dans un
métier passion qu'un métier qui me
rapporte de l'argent
[Musique]
télétravail
moi je peux pas télétravailler moi
[Musique]
pour sa reconversion à nous qui a pu
compter sur sa famille ses enfants et
son mari l'ont tous un peu aidé
oui oui bah oui un peu de cobaye j'ai
une petite séance par semaine ça va
aller le soutien indispensable pour se
lancer ça impacte toute la famille mine
de rien déjà financièrement c'était sûr
que enfin c'est sûr je souhaite bientôt
gagner autant mais c'est pas le cas donc
oui il y a une baisse de revenus
c'est un pacte pas vraiment parce que là
maintenant Lucie travaille en fait c'est
arrivé au bon moment c'était nécessaire
ouais c'était nécessaire et puis nous on
est très heureux de devoir comme ça de
devoir que tu t'épanouies que tes 10000
fois plus heureuse qu'avant enfin pour
nous arrête de me faire pleurer ça c'est
vraiment joli
avec trois grands enfants les dépenses
sont moins importantes alors sous leurs
encouragements pas question de lâcher et
oui je sais que ça fait peur de se
retrouver sans travail à 50 ans bon moi
je suis pas je suis pas sans travail
parce que je me suis créé mon travail
donc
[Musique]
voilà non j'ai pas peur moi
donc là vous avez un jardin aromatique
avec plutôt des teint des sarriettes
vous avez de Lamande en cet après-midi
divers le cours de cuisine se déplace au
potager fleurs intéressantes à avoir 20
plantes intéressante le calendula à
avoir au jardin autrement appelé aussi
le souci des jardins ça par exemple
c'est quelque chose que moi j'ai jamais
goûté j'ai hâte déjà d'aller en cuisine
de savoir qu'elle Goussard de poser des
questions au chef pour savoir comment on
peut mal utiliser au mieux
ça ouvre plein de palettes justement sur
les prochains plats qu'on va pouvoir
faire
la récolte d'aromates du jour doit leur
servir à imaginer seul une recette
faut bien qu'on choisisse des hommes
comme super différent c'est non ça va se
marier comme un taboulé un peu dyné et
en plus avec les fleurs par dessus pour
passer de cuisinier amateurs à confirmer
Yann doit être créatif mais surtout
avoir un mental solide alors le
formateur les mettant conditions
c'est un métier où on est on travaille
plus que les autres aux horaires où tout
le monde s'amuse on gagne moins d'argent
c'est un métier où on n'est pas
forcément très bien traité parce que
pendant des années ça a été tout à fait
normal de se prendre une casserole dans
la tronche parce qu'on avait raté une
maillot
vous y préparer non mais quand on sait
pas il faut qu'on apprenne quoi 39 ans à
18 à 25 c'est pareil je me suis posé la
question avant c'est non j'aurais perdu
pas mal de temps quand même dans
quelques semaines Yann se confrontera à
cette réalité lors d'un stage et même
s'il faisait de la pub avant son
expérience professionnelle devrait lui
servir comme les taboulés
plus réfléchi plus recherché parce que
ils sont là des fois au départ si on
handicap parce que il se touche un peu
sur le
sur l'intellect quoi ils sont là mais
après au fur et à mesure qui s'affirme
qui trouve leur personnalité et ça
devient un peu plus un peu plus
recherché leur cuisine j'ai pas envie de
m'arrêter de d'apprendre donc là le
projet c'est peut-être plus d'aller
travailler avec des chefs dans des
restos d'apprendre des techniques de
prendre des nouvelles cuisines
et quand il sera prêt il prévoit
toujours d'ouvrir son propre restaurant
au bord de la mer
[Musique]